the united states back fighters are
reporting significant progress in the
battle to capture the silpakorn capital
of Isis the new advance in the Syrian
city of Raqqa comes after two days of
intense fighting Holly Williams and a
CBS news crew board the first American
Network to report from inside the city
she now joins us from 40 miles outside
of Raqqa Holly good morning good morning
we've been reporting on Raqqa now for
more than three years but this was our
first chance to see inside the ISIS
stronghold for ourselves just three
weeks ago walking the streets of Raqqa
would have been suicidal for an American
TV crew but now Isis is losing its grip
besieged by US coalition airstrikes and
America's allies on the ground a ragtag
army known as the Syrian democratic
forces in more than three years under
Isis control Raqqa became a killing
field American journalists were beheaded
nearby others were crucified or thrown
from buildings and even now the
extremists are deadly
as part of our team moved forward they
were spotted by an Isis sniper our
producer Omar Abdul Qader had no choice
but to make a run for it thought they
were safe but pinned down by at least
two snipers so we are hoping either to
get but then came word there was a
suspected Isis suicide car bomb and
nearby 400 yards away these fighters
told us they'd lost five soldiers to one
of the bombs the day before they were
worried that a suicide car bomber is
coming towards the point where we were
just sitting so the vises to move over
here to take cover turned out to be a
false alarm and minutes later this
homemade armor-plated car arrived to
ferry our stranded team to safety a
close call with Isis even as its
so-called Islamic state crumbles the US
military told us there there are still
around 2,500 Isis fighters inside Raqqa
and they are now close to being entirely
surrounded Margaret Holly Williams in
Raqqa province thank you